bonjour ici mylène paquette je suis avec
la journaliste marie laure jocelyn elle
est derrière la caméra maintenant
pendant que je m'adresse à vous
alors je suis à bord du canada ces trois
brise-glaces incroyable qui va de
toronto jusqu'à victoria est aujourd'hui
mais nous sommes au nunavut dont j'ai eu
la chance d'être invité pour participer
à ça
veille aux expéditions alors ça fait
partie
de mes rêves de venir ici en articles en
arctique canadien donc j'ai la chance
d'être aujourd'hui est présentement on a
la chance de voir il fut sur bâbord un
énorme gâchis
il fut même a forcément
rentrant fond
tenter leur chance pour le voir de près
on a un capitaine extraordinaire qui
nous qui nous permettent mais plutôt
parce que
depuis dans tout local des glacis qui on
s'imagine que c'est vraiment en fait on
constate que c'est vraiment de passer
tout près sans trop se rapprocher pour
s'éloigner trop pour que tous les
participants et ce qu'il apporte plus
que voir ce magnifique morceau de glace
alors on regarde un peu à la maison
aussi
on cherche depuis depuis hier on est
arrivé hier à bord du bateau et on
cherche
ça va
premier abord
tout l'équipage ici
à apercevoir leurs cibles
donc on nous a renseignés
nous a dit des scripts et leur aisance
tu es la glace
vois ça paraît comme bleu cette classe
là
donc il faut vraiment tenter
d'apercevoir une tache jaune sur la
glace alors que la semaine dernière
le premier qui s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait un ours sur la banquise basse est
devenue la célébrité du bateau non
monde de goûter à cette liberté là tout
le monde veut apercevoir une lampe
milliards et les verse pas qu'en vue des
narvals des phoques
certains
nous vers en oeuvre d oise depuis des
l'expédition
on est là parce que on veut participer à
une démarche de réconciliation avec les
peuples des premières nations
et ben voilà c'est qu'on fait douce la
confédération canadienne
dans le temps le petit post-it de
pouvoir partager c'est quoi
c'est quoi être canada donc c'est quoi
faire partie de cette grande menace
alors il ya un salon ici qui s'appelle
en fait le salon de la ligue estime donc
c'est vraiment un endroit ont pu se
recueillir
on peut partager nos impressions et tout
à l'heure on a fait une grosse séance
des changes avec deux femmes qui sont
hissés à bord qui sont ils
et ils nous ont partagé de l'heure
de leurs traditions ancestrales
multitude qu'est ce que ça voulait dire
d'être fier de venir d'habiter
nous n'avons donc on a beaucoup apprécié
ces échanges et on a aussi on s'est un
peu comme
proposer des pistes de solution est tout
il ya aussi robert un jeune qui est né à
écolo 8 et qui nous a partagé aussi
mais qu'est ce que c'est pour mieux
d'habiter ici d'être nés ici tu partie
arrière et de revenir
donc ça a été très touchant et c'est
très très très intéressant de pouvoir
participer est donc maintenant on fersen
qu'un énorme alors on passe vraiment à
côté